hi so I'm shalota third year PhD student
in computational neuroscience and for
the coming few weeks I kind of want to
make a series on a practical skills that
I think you should develop as a student
so one of these skills is really time
management so as soon as I started my
PhD I really realized that I had to get
a lot better at managing my time and
that's just because I have so many more
responsibilities I try to finish my PhD
but I also try to upload a video to
YouTube every week and in the evenings
of course I also would like to see some
friends or have some free time or write
a little bit more creatively for my blog
and I think by getting really good at
time management you can get so much more
out of your studies and also so much
more out of your free time so today I
want to give you the top five lessons
that I've learned since my bachelor
studies off until my PhD in time
management and hopefully they will help
you as well so let's get right into it
and the first thing I really want to
talk about in this video is the one
thing so the one thing is a non-fiction
book written by Gary Keller and Jay
Papasan the book focuses on the concept
of less is more and argues that success
can be achieved by focusing on a single
important task rather than trying to do
multiple things at once so in general I
try to every day in the morning set at
least one thing that I want to
accomplish that day and this kind of
allows me to celebrate these small wins
because I think as a student you have so
many things that you try to balance
every day so for example you want to
exercise or you want to create something
on the internet but you also want to
focus on your studies and doing well for
exams and all of these can kind of
become really overwhelming and at the
end of the day what I noticed a lot of
times is that I sometimes felt as if I
didn't accomplish anything and the idea
of the one thing is really that by
trying to focus all your attention on
this one thing that day that you can
accomplish that at the end of the day
you will always feel satisfied that you
have accomplished something and
something that helps me with this is
this chrome add-on called momentum so
momentum every day gives you like a
quote and also asks you what do you want
to achieve this day and just such a
simple reminder for me really allows me
to focus on this one thing so the second
advice I have is to use a calendar and
this may seem so simple but the amount
of people that I know that don't
properly use a calendar is really
staggering so I just use the Google
Calendar and I really put everything in
there so any type of reminder everything
I have to do any type of meeting or
presentation I have to perform and
usually I also put for example if I have
an exam at the end of the month I put
two weeks beforehand to start studying
for this exam and I think by having
everything in one place you can always
just check this one place in the morning
and make a list of all all the things
that you have to achieve or accomplish
to kind of keep on top of your tasks
because as a student you just have so
many things that you have to balance
that it can become overwhelming really
quick and also something that I really
try to do is I always try to block my
Saturdays for example free such that I
almost have nothing planned on Saturdays
except for friends and seeing a movie
and relaxing time and I also put these
time blocks in for time periods that I
really want to focus on one task or
really want to do some deep work or
study for longer hours and this way also
it allows you to protect your time that
you have and become really aware of what
you're spending your time on or what
you're not spending your time on so the
third fit I have is eliminate and
delegate so after you have this calendar
and you have the concept of the one
thing you may still have a lot of tasks
in your calendar that are just at the
same time or just don't work together
and one thing that I've really noticed
is that I really had to say no to things
that are not that important and also
really try to eliminate as much as
possible for my calendar so for example
there are a lot of lectures that I could
attend at our NeuroScience Center and
even though I find a lot of them
extremely interesting and I wish I could
go to all of them I just don't really
have the time so at the beginning of the
week I really try to make a list of
which ones seem all the most interesting
or if I really like the speaker and if
none of these things are present I just
usually don't go to these lectures and I
think if you go over your calendar you
can really see what kind of things
you're spending time on that you wish
you didn't spend time on and also the
second thing of a delegate maybe if you
think of delegate you think of having
some kind of assistant which of course
you cannot afford if you're a student
but also a way you can delegate is by
thinking of AI for example so of course
all of you have seen chat GPT and all
these other AI things popping up and I
think there is really gold in using
these products in a proper manner so for
example one thing that chat GPT Can Do
Is Write already an outline for example
for a paper that you have to write or if
you have to write a motivation letter it
can give you some kind of structure and
I wouldn't recommend to have church GPT
write your entire motivation letter but
by having for example structure already
present you can kind of delegate the
task of making the most basic structure
for you to chat DPT and in general there
are a lot of AI products that can really
help with your studies and I found this
amazing website that gives a list of all
the different AI products currently out
there so I'll also put it in the
description box for you to check it out
and see if any of these AI products can
help you with your studies so before we
continue with today's video first a
little word of our sponsor Aura so when
I think of time management one of them
main things I think about is focusing so
if you have a really good ability to
focus you will become better at managing
your time as well just because in the
time that you have you are just so much
more focused and one of the ways I like
to train focus is by doing meditation
practice and these kind of daily
practices where people really teach you
how to focus for example and one app
that has been really helping me with
this is Aura Aura is a new mindfulness
and sleep app that won the best of Apple
award and is used by over 7 million
people it's an all-in-one app for your
well-being and sleep and has thousands
of meditation stories and so much more
like CBT life coaching and breath work
auras contact is created by hundreds of
expert coaches and therapists around the
world so I've been using Aura for
several days now to improve my focus and
they also have this 17 day challenge for
improving Focus that I've really been
enjoying so far so so get started for
completely free on aura's website using
my special link in the description box
the first 500 people get a free trial
exclusive 25 off yes I hope you check
Aura out but let's get straight back to
the video so the fourth thing that I
really try to focus on is this concept
of deep rest so you've probably heard of
the concept the work by called Newport
and that's really the idea that if
you're focused and in the zone you can
get a lot more work done and a lot more
difficult work done but I think kind of
a counter balance to the work of call
Newport is the idea of deep rest and a
lot of us know the concept of shallow
rest I think so that's usually when you
come home after a long day of work and
you just watch a lot of tick tock videos
to distract you from the daily stressors
of life but I think if you reflect back
on a week of doing this you kind of feel
that you're still quite stressed and
quite tense and I think the idea of deep
rest is to really remove actually all
distractions and really focus on things
that I pay for you Joy or pleasure as a
kid for example and one way that I
really like to do this is by focusing on
physical fitness body and kind of the
mind and at the moment I'm doing this
through Ashtanga Yoga so Ashtanga Yoga
is this practice where you go every
morning from like six to seven or six to
eight and you do the full primary Series
so the regular practice of Ashtanga Yoga
can improve focus reduce stress and
anxiety and also increase mental Clarity
so it's kind of like this moving
meditation for me it is really like a
kind of a gift that I give to myself
every morning by doing this and
practicing this type of meditation and
this type of yoga I've really noticed
that I have so much more clarity and I'm
also just a lot more relaxed throughout
the day and this is not to say that you
should do yoga or that you should do any
type of mindfulness training but I do
think the idea of deep breaths if you
had an entire day free what would you be
doing would you go into nature would you
take a dance class which you may meet up
with some friends and to really be
present in that moment of relaxation
without distractions I think it's
something really beautiful and something
to cultivate also in your life and the
last tip that I have and that's tip five
that's to reflect and review so I think
throughout the day we kind of get really
focused in optimizing certain parts of
our day but sometimes it's good to take
a step back and reflect and review
really what we're trying to achieve and
why we're really trying to optimize our
time so especially if you're a student
you're probably working towards some
goal so for example if you're in medical
school your final goal is to become a
doctor and maybe when you're in the
trenches of studying you're not really
focusing on this main goal but I do
think it's good every day or every week
to have a little moment where you
reflect and review on how to get to this
goal and why you want to get to the
school so I try to every morning read a
little bit of the daily story so the
daily stoic is this book with 366
meditations on wisdom perseverance and
the Art of Living and it's a book that
provides daily meditations on stoicism a
philosophy that emphasizes the
development of self-control rational
thinking and resilience in the face of
adversity and for me I just in general
really like the stoic Philosophy for
daily living and for self-development
but it also really helps me after I've
read a little bit of this book to just
Journal down my thoughts for that day
and kind of what I want to accomplish
that day and this journeying practice
doesn't have to take hours I usually
just do five minutes when I'm really
busy but I do think having this down on
paper and some of the worries that I
have and some of the goals that I want
to achieve really gives me Clarity at
the end of the week where I'm going and
exactly where I want to be so these were
my tips for personal time management and
I would love to know if you have some
kind of tips for me on how to increase
my productivity because I'm always
working on it and I'm always thinking
about it so please leave it on the
comments down below and otherwise see
you next week bye